our first year of being global we
thought we would actually go on a world
tour
Paris was awesome but now we're going to
Tokyo we have chosen united arrows I
[Music]
mean this couldn't be more Tokyo I mean
we need this in New York City
I love Tokyo it's so great to finally
arrive in Tokyo and now we get to check
out what the united arrows guys are
doing they're really extremely stylish
and they're wearing the clothes
completely different than the regions of
America opening by itself
we came to Tokyo to meet with United
arrows designers Hopi and mr. Kameda and
not only see what they were going to
design for the gaps but also like pick
your brain about style and culture and
lifestyle in Tokyo so excited about the
collaboration yeah me too
what pogey does and what mr. Kummer
Sheeta does I think of them as being
very different in a way
always still McConaughey for [ __ ]
so this is the first time we've kind of
seen the two of your designs kind of
mixed together hoagie designs all the
kind of funky you know private label
united arrows and is the buyer circle
mashita does some more tailored pieces
and does be more sartorial still in a
very japanese cool way most people when
they get off the plane in Tokyo then I
could be live to one of their stores how
many hats do you have bogie sautée 30
yeah nice I love hot the neckline as it
is now is it's it's it's a very
fashion-forward piece but I think
because the neckline is neither a crew
neck or a v-neck it might scare a few
guys off from buying it
this is my personal design but for the
faring it's very difficult
yeah that kimono is part of Japanese
culture it's very trendy to wear a
kimono and a cocconi Teresa terracotta -
Kyle I know some of that sukhavati who-
unreason oh cool Johannes wait'll I tell
you the collaborations to the cookie
knee I'm very happy that you are doing
something that's part of the soul of
United arrows and what you do the
ultimate office on these arrows kill
Miyamoto spear our story too fast from
their casinos edge of this car
the like a turtle in height there and
not traditional in a style Milan day and
all night dance together is one of my
favorite gallery Tokyo taiko is
finishing hydropower or
okay Curtis option color a little muscle
to model to you're not there are many
old Lucas twirls here here it's my
favorite prices wow that's cool this
rubber ring is 10th anniversary big
Gladys
then having that commitment
here I give you the award the GQ gap
thank you so much I looked at Japanese
culture because there's more style in
this crosswalk than there is in the
entire world I'm serious
Tokyo was a blast but now it's time to
go home Brooklyn New York to check out
kinfolk kinfolk 94 wife Avenue will like
to use passion as a Ken box count on the
cafe the stone nightclub in the back God
knows what happened in the bathroom
that's a different topic